hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente esto es lo que veremos hoy
eeuu evitó al menos por ahora el
fantasma de la sensación de pagos o
default que tendrían consecuencias para
la economía global que según las
palabras de la secretaria del tesoro
janet yellen serían catastróficas y los
papeles de pandora revelaron las
artimañas de cientos de personalidades
para evadir impuestos en paraísos
fiscales pero una de las revelaciones
más impresionantes es que uno de ellos
se encuentra en eeuu les contamos donde
el presidente de perú pedro castillo se
alejó a esta semana del ala más radical
de su partido al nombrar un nuevo
gabinete tras aceptar la renuncia a su
primer ministro
el polémico ido bellido
y vamos de inmediato a eeuu para nuestra
historia principal un acuerdo temporal
entre los republicanos y los demócratas
en el senado para elevar el techo de la
deuda evitó que la unión americana
entrará por primera vez en su historia
en sensación de pagos lo que arrastraría
consigo la economía global pero se trata
de un pacto temporal para aprobar la
subida de la capacidad de endeudamiento
del país los legisladores trajeron
además otro acuerdo inédito la
aprobación de levantar el mecanismo
conocido como filibusterismo un
mecanismo de obstrucción para poder
votar la medida el mismo día el pacto
sólo atrasa por ahora las fechas como
les explicamos en el siguiente informe
el pacto alcanzado cambia la fecha
límite del 17 de octubre al 3 de
diciembre
esa descripción este día el departamento
del tesoro agota a todos los recursos
disponibles y solo puede pagar sus
cuentas pendientes con millones de
dólares que tengan efectivo el
departamento del tesoro recibe 6 mil 750
millones por impuestos pero paga 10 mil
900 millones para los jubilados según
rositas
diez días después las reservas de
efectivo habrán disminuido
considerablemente y el valor del dólar
disminuirá
and friends esto atentaría con la
confianza en el gobierno de eeuu y en el
rol del dólar safety of dover en la
seguridad del dólar wind de forma que
nunca ha sido cuestionada el dólar es un
bien seguro cuando los tiempos son
turbulentos
hacia finales de mes cuando el gobierno
federal deba pagar a escuelas
contratistas de defensa trabajadores
hospitalarios del programa medicare y a
responsables de la seguridad social el
déficit de entre lo que washington
recibe y debe pagar se hará más profundo
es allí cuando la casa blanca puede
reestructurar su deuda externa los
inversionistas pueden aprovechar la
oportunidad para comprar más
indefinidamente pero si el temor al
default o cesación de pagos se impone y
los inversores se alejan las finanzas
del país se emplearán
cuando se cumpla el plazo de pagar los
intereses a los tenedores de los bonos y
no haya solvencia para hacerlo comenzará
a sacudirse el mercado global
[Música]
y el departamento del tesoro deberá
decidir si paga con sus ingresos
fiscales a los acreedores en el
extranjero oa los militares o adultos
mayores por ejemplo si eeuu incumple el
pago de intereses su valor estará en
duda pero si no paga a sus ciudadanos
éstos podrían quedarse sin comer y esto
sería una crisis fabricada y que
imponemos nosotros mismos en nuestro
país contra
vamos ahora a revisar la imagen de la
semana el presidente de república
dominicana luis abinader el de chile
sebastián piñera y el de ecuador
guillermo lasso son tres mandatarios
latinoamericanos en ejercicio
mencionados en los papeles de pandora la
investigación del consorcio
internacional de periodistas de
investigación icij por sus siglas en
inglés basada en la filtración de
documentos confidenciales de abogados
especializados en la creación de
sociedades en países catalogados como
paraísos fiscales pero estas son sólo
unas de las revelaciones entre otras
incluso más sorprendentes esta que a uno
de estos lugares para evadir impuestos
está dentro de eeuu dakota del sur
es conocido por el icónico monumento del
mont roig mart donde están grabados en
piedra los rostros de los presidentes
washington jefferson y roosevelt y
lincoln lo que se muestra con orgullo
pero lo que se oculta es que dakota del
sur se ha convertido con el paso del
tiempo en un paraíso fiscal es la
revelación de los papeles de pandora
367 mil millones de dólares en activos
están guardados en el estado de dakota
del tanto de fondos extranjeros como
nacionales
protegidos en un fondo de inversión
conocido como trust una estructura
jurídica que permite ocultar el nombre
detrás de un bien y mantener el
anonimato hay alrededor de 82 de ellas
el secreto fiscal se reserva y el
anonimato está garantizado
y si el sistema de arreglos financieros
tiene éxito es gracias a ciertos bancos
abogados y contadores como dakota del
sur una decena de estados
estadounidenses sobresalen en opacidad
financiera por citar algunos de la web
donde yo by the end fue senador wyoming
alaska y nevada estos territorios
también se beneficiaron del giro
impuesto en las bahamas en 2018 la ley
ahora obliga a las empresas y ciertos
fideicomisos a declarar a sus
beneficiarios finales los inversores
trasladaron desde entonces sus fondos a
eeuu sin embargo desde enero una ley
obliga a los propietarios de empresas
fachadas a revelar sus identidades más
recientemente en abril joe biden se
comprometió a luchar contra la evasión
fiscal
avergonzada por estas revelaciones la
casa blanca tuvo que reaccionar
el presidente está comprometido a
brindar mayor transparencia a los eeuu a
los sistemas financieros estadounidenses
e internacionales y se puede ver en las
políticas que ha propuesto y apoyado
durante su mandato e incluso antes
es esta ambivalencia estadounidense la
que denuncian muchos economistas y ong
washington dice que quiere luchar contra
los paraísos fiscales extranjeros al
tiempo que permite que las áreas opacas
y libres de impuestos prosperen en su
territorio
el presidente de nicaragua daniel ortega
empezó su campaña a la presidencia tras
haber despejado el camino con la
detención de decenas de opositores entre
ellos al menos siete precandidatos
presidenciales en el acto oficial de
inicio de su campaña
ortega atacó a dirigentes opositores que
se encuentran encarcelados diciéndoles
terroristas y le agrego este
calificativo a los obispos católicos que
actuaron como mediadores de un diálogo
nacional en el que se buscaba una salida
pacífica a la crisis que vive el país
según él torpedearon los intentos de
diálogo para supuestamente cumplir con
intereses estadounidenses escuchamos sus
palabras
cómplices del terrorismo
o sea lo los verdaderos responsables de
su actos de terrorismo
no era lo que estaban en los tranques
eso eran
también delincuente
pero los jefes los que organizaron todo
esto lo que armaron todo esto eran los
cuellos blancos los que no se ensucian
las manos los que no se ensucian sus
zapatillas
lo que se sienten intocables
vámonos al sur del continente el
presidente de perú pedro castillo
renuevo todo su gabinete y nombró un
grupo más moderado alejándose del ala
más radical de su partido que considera
esto como una traición pues fue clave
para llevarlo al poder pero nuevamente
pareciera estar al borde de la crisis
política tras la renuncia del polémico
primer ministro guido bellido veamos más
en el informe de luis fernando montes
desempeñar leal y fielmente el cargo de
presidente al reorganizar su gabinete
pedro castillo gira hacia la moderación
y toma distancia de la lectura de su
partido perú libre wwe ghidone
izquierdista radical que tenía una
investigación por presunta apología al
terrorismo aseguró que desconoce los
motivos de su retiro sienten hasta
nuestro cargo a disposición está en la
mesa del presidente
y el presidente la toma de decisión de
acuerdo a sus convicciones de acuerdo a
sus criterios políticos que tiene
uno cuando asume esta responsabilidad no
puede preguntar de por qué
o como
simplemente uno tiene que cumplir
todo lo que está enmarcado
en la constitución su salida será en
medio de polémicas y enfrentamientos con
el congreso bellido había amenazado con
nacionalizar uno de los principales
yacimientos de gas justo lo contrario a
la imagen de confianza empresarial que
quería trasladar castillo al mundo tras
haber sido acusado de querer llevar el
modelo chavista al perú la cuestión de
confianza
la interpelación como la censura
no deberían usarse para crear
inestabilidad política
el perú espera mucho de sus autoridades
el momento de poner al perú por encima
de toda ideología y posiciones
partidarias aisladas desde que bellido
asumió el cargo en julio su presencia
fue cuestionada por líderes de izquierda
y derecha así como parte de la
ciudadanía el ahora ex primer ministro
tuvo puntos de vista contradictorios con
pedro castillo y se vio envuelto en
escándalos por conflictos al interior
del gabinete entre las controversias
está también la denuncia de la
congresista opositora patricia chirinos
por violencia machista también venido
pidió la renuncia del ministro de
exteriores oscar maúrtua luego de que su
vicecanciller declarara no reconocer a
ninguna autoridad en venezuela como
legítima además ha defendido al gobierno
cubano al decir que en la isla existe la
democracia el uso de la lengua que hecho
en el congreso de trajo problemas con
los legisladores donde fue abucheado por
opositores que reclamaban no comprender
lo que decía gila tanaka
caracas
caminara aquí
pero marca
usted dijo que la traducción
con este cambio de gabinete del
presidente pedro castillo dio señales de
generar acuerdos en el país imaginarse
de ideologías partidistas
vamos a la frontera colombo-venezolana
que reabre el paso tras casi seis años
de cierre el gobierno de nicolás maduro
ya había cerrado de la frontera al paso
de vehículos en 2015 debido a las malas
relaciones entre ambos países pero no
fue hasta 2019 cuando el paso fronterizo
fue bloqueado con contenedores para
impedir el paso de ayuda humanitaria que
había sido recolectada a través del
concierto venezuela live que contó con
la participación de artistas como diego
torres juanes maná entre otros tras el
anuncio maduro invitó a inversionistas
colombianos mientras que el presidente
iván duque dijo que la reapertura sería
ordenada y gradual escuchamos las
palabras de las personas que habitan en
la zona
si cumplen en venezuela es muy bueno
para nosotros para comer acá ósea
volvemos a respirar más otra vez de
nuevo pero tenemos 6 años en ese mismo
en ese mismo problema de diálogo debería
haber libre este
espacio para ambos ciudadanos sin tener
ningún tipo de
preferencia por ninguno debería todos
deberíamos todos tener el derecho legal
este de pasar la frontera como dios
manda bueno esperemos que esto que se
está haciendo no sea no sea un problema
sea una causa de las elecciones que en
hábitat para venezuela verdad que no sea
un paño de agua tibia como se dice
porque entonces sería una mentira
mastica monos y
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí a américa recuerden que pueden
seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas en la
producción estuvo luis fernando montes
sigan viendo más en france 24 y france24
puntocom
[Música]